eines dieser atomkraftwerke steht in
baden württemberg neckarwestheim 2
ministerpräsident ist winfried
kretschmann von den grünen herr
ministerpräsident guten abend
guten abend herr sievers jetzt ist heute
bereits der fall eingetreten für den sie
ja vorbeugen wollen russland drosselt
weiter muss angesichts dieser lage die
kernenergie jetzt zumindest
vorübergehend weitermachen in
deutschland
es wird ja gerade in eine stresstests
geprüft
ob das notwendig ist um die stabilität
der netze auch wenn es viele ausfälle
gibt etwa im
import nicht zu baby von den
atomkraftwerken in frankreich stehen ja
viele still das wird jetzt alles genau
sehr sorgfältig geprüft
ob das notwendig ist so man dann andere
fragen wie die der
sicherheitsarchitektur zurückstellen
muss jetzt gab es ja so einer prüfung
bereits im frühjahr damals kamen
wirtschafts und umweltministerium beide
grün geführt zum ergebnis ein
weiterbetrieb bringe nichts jetzt also
die von ihnen angesprochene neue prüfung
erwarten sie da ein anderes ergebnis
das weiß ich nicht ich meine macht ja
einen stresstest um damit ergebnisse zu
haben und dann fällt man der
entscheidung das ist ein vernünftiger
weg vor herum spekulieren halte jetzt
nichts für so vernünftig jetzt gibt's ja
leute die sagen so ein stresstest ist
auch die gelegenheit für die grünen da
eine 180 grad wende hin zu bekommen
atomkraft nein danke das ist ja immerhin
so etwas wie das gründungs motto ihrer
partei
ich meine da vorn wir hätten wir auch
nicht abrücken
ich sehe auch gar niemand in der
bundesrepublik deutschland außer der afd
die wieder zurück zur atomkraft will es
geht ja nur um ein zeitlich begrenzte
eventuelle verlängerung von noch
laufenden atomkraftwerke
und das wären wir sehr nüchtern und
rational prüfen und entscheiden
wie erklären sie denn den menschen dass
in der derzeitigen situation er die
kohle weitermachen darf als die
atomkraft
war das einfach sehr viel einfacher ist
kohlekraftwerke haben wir die gehen
schon aus der reserve raus da ist jetzt
eher das problem
wir brauchen zum beispiel dafür in baden
württemberg zwei millionen zusätzlich
kohle die kann jetzt im moment nicht
ordentlich transportiert werden wenigen
wegen des niedrig standes der flüsse
also man sieht das ist auch das ist
schon schwierig aber atomkraftwerke ist
jetzt keine stereoanlage die meist
grabmal aus oder anschalten kann das
sind sehr schwierige komplexe fragen und
die müssen einfach sorgfältig geprüft
werden und im moment es ist einfach
einfacher und auch nur dadurch lösbar
das problem indem man öl und kohle
kraftwerke wieder in betrieb nimmt jetzt
gibt es noch einen anderen aspekt des
ganzen herr kretschmann sie sind ja
politprofi wenn sie jetzt bleiben bei
einer klaren ablehnung von verlängerten
atomkraft laufzeiten bei den grünen dann
und sie sind herbst hinein dann nein
sagen sie also keine klare ablehnung im
moment ist das ja die parteilinie gesagt
nein nein nein ich habe gesagt weder die
grünen noch sonst eine demokratische
partei bildet zurück zur atomkraft in
deutschland
es geht ja nur darum ob man sie jetzt
eine zeitlang weiter laufen lässt und
das wird ganz nüchtern sachlich geprüft
und je nachdem wie die prüfung auch
folgt tut man das eine oder lässt das an
gut aber durch ihr doch sehr engagiertes
nein nein nein gerade eben kann ich
jetzt doch annehmen dass diese prüfung
am ende durchaus so ausfallen könnte
dass wir ende des jahres dann erstmal
zumindest weiter auf atomkraft auch
setzen
jetzt wird geprüft
dann hat man ein ergebnis und
entscheidet und das warten wir jetzt
einfach ab das liegt ja ende august vor
es macht keinen sinn jetzt darum zu
spekulieren sie hatten heute ein gipfel
mit versorgern energieversorgern mit
vielen unternehmen mit
wirtschaftsverbänden mit kommunen bei
sich in stuttgart da ging es darum was
passiert wenn russland weiter drosselt
kaum war der gipfel vorbei trat das ein
mus land drosselt weiter ab mittwoch wie
es deutschland darauf vorbereitet
daran sieht man wie richtig der gipfel
uns sein zeitpunkt war wir müssen jetzt
darauf reagieren indem wir alle reserven
zum einsparungen zur effizienz nutzen
damit wir einfach möglichst wenig gas
verbrauchen weil dann ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit gemindert dass wir in
eine gas mangel lage kommen das ist
einfach der beitrag den wir leisten
können und wenn die schwarmintelligenz
entsteht dass betriebe das öffentliche
verwaltung jeder verbraucher einfach an
der schraube dreht und bei sich ein
spart dann können wir einfach das
problem auf jeden fall mindern
vielleicht kommen wir sogar ordentlich
durch den winter das wird sich dann
zeigen
und da das ja auch die energie verteuert
ist es auch sinnvoll dass die
unternehmen trotzdem wettbewerbsfähig
bleiben in dem sie jetzt diese reserven
mobilisieren an einsparmöglichkeiten und
auch der privatverbraucher spart ja dann
energie und spart geld und das geld
benötigt er ja um die steigende
energiepreise wenigstens zum teil
kompensieren zu können also man hat in
jedem fall was davon wenn man das macht
ist der appell des baden
württembergischen ministerpräsidenten
winfried kretschmann hat gerade von
vielen dank für das gespräch
bitteschön
[Musik]